today's protest impacted businesses
emergency runs to hospitals even forced
the closure of some streets and this has
upset many around the city global's
morgan campbell is live on bloor street
with that side of the story tonight
morgan
well mark i'm here at bloor and bedford
and you can actually see right here
behind me some transport trucks are
parked there's been just continuous
honking we've actually decided to stay
back a bit because the situation inside
is somewhat volatile now you take a look
now and uh there seems to be fewer
people but it appears they may be making
it a bit closer to queen's park let's
have a look at what things look like
earlier
today
it was a scene commuters were dreading
bloor street flooded with vehicles and
demonstrators holding signs and canadian
flags as they walked onwards to queens
park i'm here standing for everyone no
discrimination no division that's what i
believe in really really outrageous this
just one of a number of streets and
highways closed down due to the protests
demonstrators are still gathered in
ottawa and say they don't plan to go
anywhere until they meet with the
federal government primarily the prime
minister here in toronto the crowds grew
throughout the day what i worry about
is this is this series of protests for
the truckers
has you know been so negative and so
closely associated with negative
factions of society
that in fact rather than
it turning into a citizen's movement um
it may actually alienate people trying
to be truthful
manny took aim at mainstream media
condemning news coverage
[Applause]
i think the rest of the population is
watching this with with
pretty significant interest and concern
jeffrey devorkin says the attack on
mainstream media is coupled with a
breakdown in public trust due to
changing public health measures locally
federally and provincially so what we're
seeing is a lot of
disinformation being spread sometimes
deliberately sometimes inadvertently but
that's the problem
meanwhile those on the streets are
asking government officials for just one
thing we also do not want to get the
vaccine we should be respected
[Music]
so these are some of the trucks that
made it to the corner of bedford and
bloor that's about as close as they have
gotten to queen's park at this point
bloor remains closed and really mark if
anybody is trying to come into the
downtown core this evening it's probably
best that you do not there is all kinds
of traffic down here blocked off roads
and it's quite busy and of course a lot
of different demonstrators here at the
end of the day it's really unclear how
long people are going to remain here but
toronto's police chief has made it quite
clear that he does not want to see a
repeat of what we're experiencing right
now at parliament hill mark all right
also seems very loud there right now
morgan that's global's morgan campbell
reporting for us tonight thanks a lot